I like to give updates about my life as a single mom now
to encourage other mothers
so that you don't have to stay in a shitty marriage
because you're married with somebody.
And I love when in the comments,
the ladies chime in and give their story,
because you can see, you don't have to stay with somebody
just because you had kids with them.
You don't have to stay with somebody just because at one time you said,
okay, I vow this and that will. Shit.
Shit changes, okay?
You can get remarried with four kids
and have somebody that's kind and helpful.
It's. It's not that hard.
It's not the end of the world.
You know the men who are saying
you're never gonna find somebody to love you?
That's their fucking opinion.
There's plenty of men that do not see children as a repellent.
They're not, like,
all gonna run away just because some guys, like,
who gives a fuck? Those are your fucking kids.
And especially when you have that attitude,
that mentality, these are my kids.
We are a package deal. But,
you know, you're not.
You're not their father. You're not.
I'm not asking you to do anything more than just be with me
and be nice to them and just see what happens.
And there's plenty of men that will do that.
You do not need to stay with somebody just because you have kids.
And just because you have kids,
that's Not gonna be an automatic rejection from other people